I had it all man fast calls best friends
extremely young women but them thick
skin Hokies took the one thing that
mattered most
my chair
it's not what you did son it's who you
did it too the greatest assassin to ever
leave from a professional killer
handsome wise and articulate Once Upon
almost confirmed we were in there you
can take him out away from our word he's
also really good at guitar and he did it
all sitting down
old habits die hard
they gonna have to pay for what they
done have you returned
I get back in I need resources let me
tack up
wait it's
standing no I'm running
you run you die you gotta tell me
straight so I can know who's coming for
us our pleasure it's like a monkey
trying to [__] football now really
what have you done we've just succeeded
inverting these [__] to the ground
you uh working again yeah
I'm thinking I'm black
hey you you might be wondering why we
made this monstrosity and how it's a
really healthy question and if you need
that it scratched you can see the full
video of how we made this on the
corridor crew YouTube channel that's
right hop on over Corridor crew on
YouTube do it do it